now sadly Biden and his borders are
Kamala Harris they are totally ignoring
this crisis as per usual today Joe
called the lid at 3 P.M in the afternoon
barely worked all day and it's obvious
that Biden does not possess the mental
or the physical stamina to be president
now that's why his fellow Democrat well
Gavin Newsom is all but measuring the
drapes in the Oval Office in spite of
what he might be saying publicly in
keeping with tradition Newsome is
looking to fail up just like Biden
Harris and good old pothole Pete now
keep in mind many years ago Gavin
newsom's home state of California was
one of the places to live in the country
one of the best places California is now
dying hemorrhaging population at an
alarming rate this is a very real
phenomenon it hadn't happened in 175
years and it will have long-term serious
consequences for that state in fact for
the first time in history California is
on track to lose population for the
third straight Year great job Gavin in
2022 California's net migration was
negative 343
000. now think about that that's nearly
a thousand people a day leaving the
state and new people not moving in to
replace those that are leaving let's
contrast California with California they
have a net gain of more than 318 000
people moving into uh Florida in other
words Florida's gaining almost a
thousand new residents every single day
it's good for their economy now why are
people fleeing California and flocking
in droves to Florida for starters well
California's uh tax rate is downright
abusive well while Floridians pay zero
income tax zero percent now the income
tax rate in California can be as high as
12.3 percent that is the highest in the
entire country property tax says they're
also incredibly High even the state
sales tax is higher than Florida's and
expect those taxes to go even higher
because California now is losing more
population and Gavin Newsom his current
budget deficit is more than 22 billion
dollars and going higher now meanwhile
DeSantis finished the year with a record
22 billion dollar budget surplus take a
look at your screen High tax states like
California Illinois New York and New
Jersey all experience negative migration
in 2022 while Texas Florida Tennessee
the Carolinas Utah Idaho all saw massive
gains and it's not only just about taxes
because you know a lot of this is
related to the burdensome government
regulations surrounding development for
example California and many of these
other liberal states they are
experiencing a severe housing shortage
now why would they have a housing
shortage when so many people are leaving
well that's because because prices are
soaring making these states unaffordable
because it costs so much more to build
the house because of all the burdensome
regulation and by the way at that point
it becomes unaffordable for many
Americans as a result California's
homeless population is now the largest
by far in the country and then to make
matters worse you have woke criminal
justice policies zero bail defund
dismantle the police lacks prosecution
and destroying California's major cities
which are limited littered with open air
drug markets and all these homeless
encampments California is also home to
one of the largest populations of
illegal immigrants not only is
California a sanctuary state but it also
provides cash benefits and
taxpayer-funded health care to millions
of illegal immigrants and free education
and free health care and free pretty
much everything and meanwhile
law-abiding Californians they are now
forced to adapt to new restrictions
every single year including bans on gas
powered mowers and chainsaws and other
equipment and more disturbing than that
the state schools and other institutions
they are obsessed with Equity critical
race Theory and let's not forget
California was also home to some of the
worst coveted lockdowns in the country
of course that didn't affect Gavin
Newsom he continued to enjoy his
fanciful dinners out with friends when
nobody else in California could most
restaurants were not allowed to be
opened at the time he was enjoying that
dinner his kids they remained in his
private schools that he was paying for
meanwhile all the kids in California and
public schools they were not allowed to
attend school in person schools in
Florida for example they opened
successfully in August of 2020 and by
the way no mask mandates either so make
no mistake Newsome is a terrible
politician a sad excuse for a leader and
recently while multiple counties in
Calif California were experiencing a
State of Emergency due to severe winter
weather Newsom he was out enjoying a
tropical vacation in Mexico now compare
that to Governor DeSantis his leadership
in the wake of the hurricane hurricane
Ian it is not a mystery there is a
reason California New York Illinois New
Jersey and all these other states are
dying and Florida Texas the Carolinas
and Tennessee are flourishing take a
look
when the world went mad Florida stood as
a refuge of Sanity a citadel of freedom
for people throughout the United States
and indeed throughout the world we
empowered people to make their own
choices and if you look over the last
four years we've witnessed a great
American Exodus from States governed by
leftist politicians imposing leftist
ideology and delivering poor results in
Florida we will never surrender to the
woke mob our state is where woke goes to
die
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else